[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es amalfman Y estos son los
titulares
Cecilia oficialmente la reconciliación
entre España y Marruecos pero a Costa de
numerosas concesiones del gobierno de
Pedro Sánchez en particular sobre la
cuestión de la política marroquia
respecto del Sahara occidental
en Liberia George ha elegido presidente
en 2017 anunció su candidatura a las
próximas elecciones presidenciales de
octubre repasamos sus seis años al
frente de este estado de África
occidental y nos vamos a Brasil Como
cada año el 2 de febrero miles de
personas rindieron homenaje a emanja la
Diosa del océano una divinidad mítica
para los afrodescendientes de este país
fue la primera cumbre en 8 años entre
Madrid y rabat tuvo lugar después de que
el gobierno español aceptara las
condiciones marroquíes sobre el estatus
del disputado Sahara occidental en los
últimos años la relación entre España y
Marruecos ha atravesado fuertes crisis y
fue en mayo de 2021 cuando las tensiones
alcanzaron su punto máximo Aquí están
los momentos más críticos en los
vínculos entre los dos países desde 2021
los días 17 y 18 de mayo de 2021
Marruecos no se opuso la entrada de más
de 10.000 migrantes entre ellos cientos
de menores en el enclave español de
ceuta se trataba de una represalia por
la acogida y hospitalización en España
de Brain Gali líder del movimiento
independentista saharaui frente
polisario que tenía Kobe 19
el 18 de marzo de 2022 España cambió
radicalmente su posición
tradicionalmente neutral sobre su
antigua Colonia del Sáhara occidental en
una carta al rey marroquí Mohamed sexto
el presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez calificó de serio realista y
creíble al plan de Marruecos para la
autonomía del Sáhara occidental todos
los partidos españoles condenaron la
decisión
el giro sobre el Sáhara occidental se
vio recompensado con un encuentro el 7
de abril de 2022 entre Sánchez y Mohamed
vi tras la reunión las rutas marítimas
fueron reabiertas así como las fronteras
terrestres de ceuta y melilla para los
europeos
en mayo de 2022 los ministros de
interior de ambos países reactivaron su
cooperación Y decidieron volver a
trabajar juntos especialmente en materia
de migración algo que mantienen alerta
organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos el 24 de junio de 2022 al menos
23 migrantes murieron después de que la
gendarmería marroquí interviniera
brutalmente para impedir que ellos y
varios centenares más cruzarán las
vallas que separan la ciudad marroquí de
nador del enclave español de melilla el
gobierno de España respaldó el accionar
de las autoridades marroquíes
en los últimos meses Pedro Sánchez ha
insistido en lo que considera la
importancia estratégica para España y
para la Unión Europea de tener las
mejores relaciones con Marruecos y como
decíamos fue en rabat la capital
marroquí donde ambos países es
significaron su Reconciliación nuestra
corresponsal Sofía catala analiza las
conclusiones e implicaciones de esta
Cumbre
si la reunión de alto nivel entre España
y Marruecos concluyó con la firma de
cantidad de acuerdos y compromisos de
entendimiento que tienen implicaciones
principalmente sobre El Sahara
occidental el control migratorio y los
Derechos Humanos esta Cumbre sirvió para
escenificar el inicio de una nueva era
de sintonía diplomática entre países
vecinos que pone fin a la crisis que
atravesaron en los últimos años una
crisis que recordemos empezó a
solucionarse cuando el gobierno español
tomó parte por el estado marroquí en el
conflicto del Sáhara occidental Pues
bien esta Cumbre vino a sellar dicho a
compromiso y es que España reiteró su
apoyo al plan de autonomía que propone
Marruecos para resolver el conflicto del
Sáhara frente al referéndum de
autodeterminación que exigen los
independentistas del frente polisario
por su parte Marruecos Se comprometió a
cambio una vez más a reforzar el control
migratorio lo que quiere decir
intensificar las medidas de represión
contra migrantes y solicitantes de asilo
para impedir que lleguen territorio
español cabe recordar que España y
Bruselas pagan cantidades millonarias
anualmente a Marruecos en el marco de la
externalización del control migratorio
de la Unión Europea y Marruecos
aprovecha este papel de gendarme de las
fronteras también para intentar lograr
sus propias metas diplomáticas por otra
parte en la Cumbre los gobiernos de
España y Marruecos se comprometieron a
no ofenderse mutuamente como principio
fundamental de su nueva relación y esto
es especialmente relevante para
Marruecos en los relativos sobre todo a
estrechar lazos con sus socios europeos
y es que España presidirá a partir de
Julio el consejo de la Unión Europea
además cabe recordar que hace unas
semanas el parlamento europeo aprobó una
resolución condenando la falta de
libertad de prensa aquí en Marruecos una
resolución que si bien no es vinculante
si afecta la imagen Internacional del
país magreb que precisamente no pasa por
su mejor momento hace años que
organizaciones internacionales como
amnistía internacional
Sin fronteras entre otras denuncian la
persecución que sufren aquí los
periodistas persecución que aseguran se
basa en la instrumentalización de
delitos sexuales por parte del Estado
para callar a las voces críticas sonados
son los casos de los periodistas
que actualmente se encuentran
encarcelados precisamente por supuestos
delitos sexuales que jamás pudieron
llegar a probarse en lo que ya es un
patrón que no deja de repetirse
cambiamos de tema georges a presidente
de Liberia Apuesta por un nuevo mandato
se ha declarado oficialmente candidato a
las elecciones presidenciales de octubre
de 2023 en el siguiente informe hacemos
un repaso de sus años en el poder
de niño de los barrios marginalizados a
Estrella internacional de fútbol y luego
jefe de estado tras seis años al frente
de Liberia el presidente George wea ha
anunciado su candidatura para un segundo
mandato consecutivo
pronto acudiría a ustedes para pedirles
que renueven por segunda vez el mandato
que me confiaron hace 6 años
[Música]
Déjenme asegurarles que el estado de
nuestras naciones fuerte
el estado de nuestra nación es estable
es vibrante es joven es Pacífico y
seguro e intentaremos que siga siendo
así
fue a único balón de oro africano
reconvertido en político fue elegido en
ex estrella de hace Milán y del París
saint-germain su popularidad era alta
entre las clases de favorecidas y su
Victoria había suscitado enormes
esperanzas en un país asolado por Las
Guerras civiles y una epidemia de ébola
wea prometió crear empleo invertir en
educación y erradicar la corrupción Pero
según sus críticos ha cumplido muy pocas
de sus promesas y la corrupción persiste
hoy hemos venido a decir que estamos
cansados de este sufrimiento endémico
que mata a nuestro pueblo
nuestra reunión de hoy aquí enviará una
señal a la comunidad internacional de
estamos cansados de todo lo que estaba
ocurriendo en nuestro país
el país de unos cinco millones de
habitantes se vio además afectado por la
pandemia de covid-19 y después por las
consecuencias de la guerra en Ucrania
que provocó escasez de productos básicos
y una nueva subida de precios
recientemente el presidente fue
criticado por su prolongada ausencia del
país ha pasado unos 40 días en
conferencias y Cumbres y también en el
mundial de Qatar sus opositores lo
acusan de no estar en contacto con la
realidad de sus conciudadanos cerca de
la mitad de los liberianos viven con
menos de 1.9 dólares al día según el
Banco Mundial
hacía un siglo que no sonaba en su país
un tambor marfileño de Gran valor
confiscado por Francia durante la
colonización está a punto de ser
devuelto a Costa de Marfil esto se
enmarca en una nueva etapa de la
política de restitución de obras
saqueadas a África iniciada en 2017 por
el presidente francés Emmanuel maccoll
Pero antes de que pueda ser devuelto
tuvieron que restaurar el tambor de Amos
es un trabajo meticuloso hecho de
paciencia de observación
pese a su tamaño y a su peso casi cuatro
metros por media tonelada este tambor se
ha vuelto muy frágil con los estragos
del tiempo
tiene más de un siglo y ha sido atacado
por insectos xilófagos antes de su
conservación en Francia
se trata Pues de consolidar la madera en
su estructura para que recupere una
cierta densidad una cierta coherencia y
una solidez que permitan manipularla y
también consolidar las zonas frágiles de
la superficie
este tambor fue confiscado en Costa de
Marfil por el ejército francés durante
la colonización a principios del siglo
XX traído a Francia en los años 1930
pasó sucesivamente a formar parte de las
colecciones de varios museos franceses
hasta llegar al museo que goldie
el sonido de este tambor de hendidura
tallado en el tronco de un árbol de
madera dura permitía la comunicación a
través de su sonido se convirtió en el
símbolo de la resistencia anticolonial
ya que permitía la comunicación entre
los pueblos y la gente durante la
colonización
una vez finalizada la restauración de
este tambor de guerra será embalado
listo para ser enviado de vuelta a su
país de origen una restitución que
debería tener lugar durante el año 2023
dejamos el continente y nos dirigimos a
Brasil donde cada año el dos de febrero
miles de personas se rinden homenaje a
la Diosa del mar llevan Ya llevan ya es
una orilla una deidad originaria de
Nigeria adorada por los adeptos del
candomble y de otras religiones de raíz
africana es considerada la patrona de
Los Pescadores también es conocida como
la divinidad de la fertilidad y del amor
en Río de Janeiro la celebración ocurrió
en la icónica playa de ipanema al ritmo
de los tambores africanos Este es un
reportaje de nuestra corresponsal
Valeria sacone
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se hacen Llamar las hijas de Gandhi
danzan en la foché una música afro
brasileña para rendir homenaje a e-man
ya la diosa de los océanos
y estamos en el fondo estamos llevando
una ofrenda A yaman ya la reina del mar
esta gran madre que atravesó el mar con
nosotros cuando veníamos de África
nuestros tejidos nuestras danzas
nuestros cantos nuestros gestos todo
viene de África
[Música]
fieles de muchos Terreros como son
llamados los templos afro han llegado
hasta la playa de panema la más famosa
de Brasil para festejar a la divinidad
más querida del candomblé
las ofrendas están listas hay muchas
flores y regalos 100% biodegradables
para evitar más polución en la Bahía de
guanábara
Dario es babalorishá Es decir el
sacerdote del candomblé que lidera esta
celebración
aprendimos de los africanos a adorar que
es una diosa Yoruba de una región de
Nigeria entonces llaman ya llega a
Brasil junto a lo que hoy llamamos
candomblé desde los años 40 los devotos
Se entregan presentes a yeman ya en esta
playa pero con el tiempo esta tradición
se perdió y solo fue recuperada
recientemente Nos pasamos por un periodo
hemos pasado por un periodo pesado con
un alcalde evangélico entonces Muchas
fiestas populares como esta fueron
prohibidas en Río de Janeiro y Hoy
estamos volviendo creemos en un nuevo
Brasil con todo lo que está pasando y
pedimos a yeman ya que es la dueña de
las cabezas que nos proteja y nos
conduzca
la procesión avanza a la orilla donde
les espera una yeman ya negra para el
último Ritual del día
reza una leyenda que esta fiesta comenzó
hace exactamente un siglo en Salvador de
bahía cuando 25 Pescadores ofrecieron
regalos a la diosa pidiendo peces en
abundancia 100 años después millares de
personas siguen confiando en el poder de
yemannya
así termina la edición de esta semana
Gracias por acompañarnos la actualidad
internacional sigue en France 24
[Música]